[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
ya el bolsón ario cometió crímenes
contra la humanidad por no actuar a
tiempo frente al kobe 19 y causó la
muerte de al menos 300.000 de las más de
600.000 personas fallecidas por
coronavirus en brasil esta es la
denuncia del senado que avaló una
investigación de seis meses de su
gestión de la pandemia
una vez más el debate por el control de
armas se toma a eeuu tras la muerte de
halle na hudgins en el set de grabación
con un disparo del actor alec baldwin se
alzan las voces para prohibir armamento
real en los estudios pero otras lo piden
en todos los ámbitos
quim vila una comunidad maya en el
estado mexicano de yucatán es conocida
como la capital de la moda y esto en
parte es gracias a que muchos hombres
decidieron olvidarse de la agricultura
para comenzar a abordar un oficio que
anteriormente estaba reservado para las
mujeres
y vamos de inmediato a brasil para
nuestra historia principal el senado ha
respaldado los cargos criminales en
contra del presidente ya ir bolsonaro
por su gestión de la pandemia del cob y
19 un informe de 1200 páginas lo acusa
de aminorar la enfermedad y cuestionar
la efectividad de las vacunas exponiendo
a los brasileños a contagios masivos
brasil es el segundo país del mundo con
más fallecidos por kobe 19 además es el
sexto con más contagios el comité del
senado no tiene el poder de imputar los
cargos y es poco probable que el fiscal
general quien si puede hacer no lo haga
porque puede nombrado por el propio
bolsonaro y tampoco está en el panorama
que el presidente de la cámara baja-
inicia el proceso de destitución en su
contra porque también es su aliado
el actor está aprobado por siete votos a
cuatro
caso cerrado tras seis meses de
investigación el martes los senadores de
brasil aprobaron un informe que
recomienda que se investigue al
presidente ya ir bolsonaro por cargos
que van desde malgastar fondos públicos
hasta crímenes en contra de la humanidad
por su fallida respuesta a la pandemia
esa responsabilidad de mucha gente hay
muchos indiciados las responsabilidades
de muchas personas muchas están
imputadas pero la principal
responsabilidad es de el presidente ya
ir bolsonaro este asesino en serie que
tiene una obsesión por la muerte y sigue
repitiendo todo lo que ha dicho en el
pasado y el informe de 1.200 páginas
urgió también a la corte suprema del
país a suspender las redes sociales de
bolsonaro por desinformar continuamente
sobre el cobre y 19 de hecho facebook y
youtube suprimieron una publicación del
presidente de ultraderecha que decía que
las personas que están completamente
vacunadas tienen más posibilidades de
contraer sida junto a otros 77 de sus
allegados los tres hijos de bolsonaro
son mencionados en el documento lo que
les dio pie para responder a lo que
creen es una calumnia extrema mente
este es un informe extremadamente débil
jurídicamente hablando un informe
político que no ha otorgado ningún
beneficio al pueblo brasileño y su apoyo
las sombras del líder es poco probable
que bolsonaro deba abandonar su cargo o
vaya a prisión ya que solamente el
fiscal general podría presentar cargos
en su contra hoy presidente de la cámara
baja iniciar un proceso de impeachment
los dos fueron nombrados por el el cargo
de crímenes contra la humanidad podría
ser eventualmente juzgado por la corte
penal internacional sin embargo el
informe le añade peso a su ya devastada
popularidad de cara a las elecciones
presidenciales de 2022 en las que se
enfrenta al ex presidente luiz inácio
lula da silva por la reelección
seguimos hablando de la corte penal
internacional porque esta semana cerró
la investigación que adelantaba sobre la
solidez de la justicia transicional en
colombia el gobierno colombiano y la cpi
firmaron un acuerdo que archiva el
proceso que revisaba las investigaciones
sobre crímenes de guerra cometidos entre
2009 y de lesa humanidad desde 2002
perpetrados tanto por el ejército de la
extinta guerrilla de las farc y los
grupos paramilitares el presidente iván
duque se comprometió a seguir apoyando
el proceso de paz pero la jurisdicción
especial para la paz la gp ha criticado
al gobierno de eduque porque no apoya lo
suficiente a la justicia transicional y
le ha disminuido el presupuesto
y seguimos en eeuu la trágica muerte de
la directora de fotografía salina
hudgins cuando el actor alec baldwin le
disparó con un arma de utilería ha
reactivado el debate sobre el uso de
armamento en los sets de grabación en
eeuu un senador de california anunció
que presentará un proyecto de ley para
prohibir el uso de munición real en los
estudios del estado que es el hogar de
hollywood mientras que otros piden que
se impongan mayores controles al porte
de armas en todos los ámbitos el último
adiós al inah hudgins la mayoría de los
asistentes al funeral eran amigos
cercanos y colegas de la cinematógrafo
la mujer de 42 años recibió un disparo
del actor alec baldwin que usó el arma
de utilería en el set de rost su muerte
ha conmocionado a hollywood su muerte no
debió ocurrir los sets deberían ser
seguros cada persona merece trabajar con
toda la seguridad sabiendo que pueden
llevar a cabo su trabajo y regresar a
casa con tranquilidad el fatal tiroteo
despertó un debate sobre el uso de armas
en los set
el llamado crece ahí
las medidas de seguridad
sólo un día después de la muerte se
lanzó una petición para pedir que las
armas sean prohibidas en las grabaciones
se han recolectado miles de firmas
generalmente estamos contra el tiempo y
tenemos que acelerar aún más así que no
se llevan a cabo los protocolos de
seguridad tenemos que hacer lo mejor que
podamos con lo que tenemos y eso lleva a
accidentes algunos insisten que usar
armas en los sets de grabación puede ser
seguro
no tengo un problema con las armas en el
set solamente es necesario que vengan de
las manos correctas y solo deberían ser
manejadas con seguridad a través de los
asistentes de dirección o del director
para que sea seguro
otros ya tomaron una decisión solo un
día después del incidente los
productores del drama policial de rocky
prohibieron de manera inmediata el uso
de municiones reales
el éxito gobernador de nueva york andrew
cuomo que dimitió en agosto después de
ser señalado de acoso sexual y
comportamiento inapropiado fue
denunciado formalmente por tocamientos
forzosos un delito sexual menor en nueva
york' un portavoz del tribunal de la
corte de albany y confirmó la denuncia y
señaló que pronto estará disponible una
copia censurada de la demanda pues se
trata de un crimen sexual
vamos ahora a méxico en kimbilá es
posible ver esta imagen cotidianamente
hombres diseñando creando y detrás de
los hilos y de las máquinas y es que
tras una prolongada sequía tras el paso
del huracán isidoro en 2002 muchos
hombres decidieron olvidarse de la
agricultura y probar suerte con el
bordado un oficio que en méxico es
usualmente popular entre las mujeres hoy
las nuevas generaciones lo ven como un
trabajo más nuestra enviada especial
katia espinoza nos trae la historia
enrique comenzó a bordar a los 12 años
de manera empírica y ahora se dedica al
oficio que hasta hace unos años sólo
estaba destinado a las mujeres la imagen
se repite en toda la comunidad hombres
detrás de los hilos se dedicaron al
bordado después de que el huracán
gilberto en 1988 dañó los campos para
agricultura cuando vino a gilberto
todo en el de la musa de que se echaron
a perder porque la lluvia que cayó lo
quemó
y ya el trabajo ya no hay trabajo ya la
gente se empezó a
aprender más el bordado
y cómo se abrió la fábrica algunos
podrán a la bolsa aprendieron a abordar
a costuras rectas o sea la gente buscó
tiene que hacer porque sobrevivir y que
hay otros hombres ahora diseñan crean
yacente quim vila una comunidad maya al
oriente del estado mexicano de yucatán
la capital yucateca de la moda el taller
de bordados que quema y es una
institución en el diseño y su trabajo ha
trascendido a otros países como españa
cuba brasil y república dominicana-
técnicas artesanales que han pasado de
generación en generación hoy jóvenes
como víctor a sus 30 años están al mando
de este taller y dan empleo a más de 20
personas una de las cosas que sí como
que sí hemos estado como que
persiguiéndole y tratar de llegar a
otros lugares es como que tratar de
llevar esto a una gran pasarela digamos
demostrar de que también lo que hacemos
está a la altura de
unas grandes marcas que no tienen tanto
artesanal y nosotros conservan esa parte
artesanal del estado ya y del país
entonces si llevarlo a otros hogares
sería muy muy satisfactorio y poder
llegar en la localidad maya de poco más
de tres mil habitantes estos hombres han
roto estereotipos y le han dado una
identidad propia al poblado lo mejor es
que las mujeres bordadoras de quim vila
están orgullosas del trabajo que ellos
hacen
sigamos en mexico para hablar del día de
muertos una tradición en honor a las
almas de los difuntos las familias
honran a sus seres queridos fallecidos
con altares música y celebraciones pero
la tradición maya incluye incluso la
limpieza de los huesos de los familiares
fallecidos les contamos más en el
siguiente informe
el día de los muertos en méxico rompe
con la forma en la que la mayoría del
mundo ve lo inevitable y aquí en pomuch
los habitantes llevan la tradición
incluso un poco más lejos a limpiar los
huesos de los fallecidos es una
tradición maya para los indígenas la
muerte enmarca un renacimiento otra fase
de un viaje eterno es una tradición muy
bonita recordar a nuestros antepasados
tenerlos en cuenta hacer la limpieza de
sus usarios donde reposan sus restos sus
huesitos y pues les cambiamos sus
manteles porque pues si llega el día de
la fiesta en que ellos están contentos
que los recordamos con mucho cariño y
mucho amor
entre canciones e historias las familias
cuidando restos de sus seres queridos
durante varias horas
el ritual suspendido en 2020 debido a la
pandemia tiene lugar cada año a partir
del tercer año después de la muerte del
ser querido yo desa de maría llena eres
de gracia señores pumpido 20 tú eres
abrió la tumba saca dos cajas
se acaba de mantener una cerveza
limpiamos bien la caja y ponemos el paño
nuevo limpiamos los huesos y ya de
último ya está listo podemos acomodarnos
aquí en bastante después de la limpieza
los residentes de pomuch y de otros
lugares de méxico levantan altares en
sus hogares previo al día de los muertos
que se celebra el primero de noviembre
en 2008 unesco inscribió la tradición en
la lista de patrimonio cultural
intangible de la humanidad
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américas hoy natalia cabrera y
pueden seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo joan y agudelo sigan
viendo más en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]
cada 30